aujourd'hui dans l'industrie les poulets
sont élevés à 2 fin bien différente il
ya d'une part les poules pondeuses qui
donne des oeufs et d'autre part des
poulets qui sont élevées pour la chair
mais la croissance très rapide de ces
poulets moderne a un impact négatif sur
leur santé et leur bien-être
qui peut définir le bien-être animal
comment on s'aperçoit qu'un poulet est
heureux
le bien-être animal pour moi c'est pas
seulement par les conversions
élémentaire croissance
c'est d'avoir des oiseaux qui vont jouer
entre all bat des ailes à les manger
boire se reposer
[Musique]
les poulets co epicor ça pour moi c'est
un bien-être animal optimum
le poulet c'est la protéine animale la
plus consommée dans le monde pour
nourrir la planète l'industrie a
sélectionné au fil des ans des lignes et
génétiques capables de gagner du poids
rapidement de nos jours la conversion
alimentaire est si efficace que les
poulets sont quatre fois plus groupe
dans les années 50 leur poitrine 80%
plus volumineuse mais ses performances
se sont faites au détriment de la santé
des volatiles
[Musique]
partout dans le monde les poulets élevés
de façon conventionnelle ont des
problèmes de mobilité
une marche difficilement ce qui entraîne
des problèmes de boiterie à force de
rester assis les poulets développe des
lésions au pacte au jarret et à la
poitrine
les poulets sont envoyés à l'abattoir à
35 jours ils sont conçus pour croître si
rapidement qu'il devienne très gros et
peuvent à peine marcher parfois
lorsqu'ils arrivent à l'abattoir
les organismes de défense des droits des
animaux comme celui pour lequel
travaillent les kavanagh ont depuis
longtemps tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur
le sort des poules est à croissance
rapide
les poulets à croissance rapide de sont
élevés dans des poulaillers bondé avec
des cycles de noirceur limitée afin
qu'ils mangent et grossistes rapidement
gros progrès
pour savoir comment ça se passe dans les
poulaillers nous avons demandé aux plus
important éleveur de la province de nous
montrer leurs installations mais ils ont
refusé la seule qui a accepté ces jaunes
cameron qui possède un très petit
élevage à saint charles sur richelieu je
trouve que c'est important d'éduquer les
consommateurs pourront peut briser
l'image idyllique d'abord quelques
poules elle est élevée dans un pâturage
où on pense maintenant que c'est comme
ça que le canton voit plus la réalité
mais le quai il ya un clash qui est très
important on fait juste augmenter les
corps de connaissance puis de
compréhension entre les gens de la ville
puis la production agricole
la première chose que je fais le matin
c'est vraiment voir l'ordinateur de
contrôle du poulailler c'est ici que je
vois tous les paramètres qui sont reliés
au bien être puissante et des animaux
par exemple présentement je partage en
1570 poulette c'est des femelles qui ont
28 jours
le jour de notre visite les poulettes de
johan cameron était enfin d'élevage ici
comme dans tout les poulaillers à
croissance rapide les volatiles n'ont
pas de lumière naturelle ils vont pas à
l'extérieur la densité tourne autour
d'une quinzaine d'oiseaux ou m²
traditionnellement s'est défoulé sur
plus de pros dermatite qui sont pas très
mobile défaillance cardiaque tout ça à
quelle fréquence à survient ici c'est
pas quelque chose que moi j'observe le
directement par rapport à ça c'est
vraiment une quantité infime si cela
arrive on travaille vraiment plus dans
la prévention pourquoi atteindre ce
problème at cyclope j'avais remis en
cause
c'est un très bon éleveur joies des
sports attentive la garantie qu'on
trouvera tous les jours s'assurait que
l'environnement intérieur est bien
contrôlée benoît lanthier c'est l'ex
vétérinaire de johan cameron il
travaille maintenant pour une compagnie
qui sélectionne les caractéristiques
génétiques des poulains dans le monde il
fait valoir que les maladies osseuses ou
cardiaques sont en voie d'être contrôlé
par l'industrie on continue encore à
faire de la recherche pour éliminer tout
problème potentiel qui peut y avoir
les poulets qu'on a aujourd'hui qui ont
toutes les bonnes conditions au niveau
nutrition au niveau environnement ils
n'ont pas de problème à se déplacer mais
ce n'est pas toujours le cas dans ce
poulailler que nous avons visités en
2017 des poulets obèses avaient de la
difficulté à se mouvoir d'autres ne
pouvez carrément plus marcher pour aller
s'alimenter sans compter celui ci mort
depuis quelques heures une situation due
à la surpopulation dans le poulailler à
un niveau sanitaire déficient ou un
stress trop élevé chez les animaux
consommés wright les consommateurs
aiment penser que les animaux sont bien
traités on ne publie six pas le sort
réservé aux poulets élevés pour aboutir
rapidement dans les supermarchés a
marqué
les gens aiment avoir de la viande à bon
marché mais ils veulent aussi que les
poulets est une vie formidable en plein
air les deux ne vont pas ensemble
d'études aurel or donc outsider
la chercheuse tinner we love ski et son
équipe viennent de terminer une étude
sur la vitesse de croissance des poulets
les poulets à croissance rapide
conventionnelle et d'autres à croissance
lente a battu à 62 jours un des tests
consistaient à mettre des accessoires
dans les poulaillers dès
les poules est conventionnelle passé
beaucoup plus de temps à 6 il marchait -
est resté debout moins longtemps
il utilisait moins les accessoires parce
qu'ils perdent l équilibre ou avait
peine à grimper les obstacles ont aussi
été mis en travers du chemin menant à
l'eau et à la nourriture de burns
les oiseaux à qui on donnait des
antidouleurs franchissait ces obstacles
plus
cette validation nous indique que
l'absence de mouvement peut être dû à la
douleur de
sa conclusion
plus la croissance est lente - il y a
deux lacunes en matière de bien-être
animal
si on avait un peu plus la croissance
larmes qui montent on va plus de mourir
pour un plus de terre on n'aurait pas
les informations nécessaires au québec
pour produire le poulet qu'on a pour
honorer nos populations ça me rendrait
beaucoup plus de champ beaucoup plus
d'eau beaucoup de profs en hiver pour
chauffer les bâtiments
et
oui le poulet à croissance rapide peut
réduire l'empreinte environnementale
en revanche l'oiseau souffre pour qu'on
ait une source de protéines à rabais
en
e
on a très peu de poulet qui meurent de
crise cardiaque ou dans le transport ou
quoi que ce soit parce qu'évidemment
sont plus vieux sont plus résistants
damien girard élève des poulets à
croissance lente à saint-urbain dans
charlevoix ces volatiles sont envoyés à
l'abattoir presque deux fois plus vieux
que les poulets à croissance rapide
un poulet de 63 jours qui pèse seulement
3 kg la croissance a été moins rapide
donc il ya beaucoup moins de difficultés
à se mouvoir sur ses jambes a couru ou à
se lever
[Musique]
rien dans la certification biologique
que l'éleveur détient ne l'obligent à
élever du poulet à croissance lente si
damien girard a fait ce choix c'est pour
obtenir une chaire différentes
on voulait que le consommateur retrouve
un peu poulet d'autres fois on voulait
donner le temps au poulet aussi de quoi
puis faire plus de ceinture puis de
musculature puis deux tendons puis le
poulet goûte plus le poulet ce que la
certification biologique l'obligé à
faire c'est d'envoyer ses poulets à
l'extérieur quand la température le
permet et à les élever à la lumière
naturelle la densité doit aussi être
moindres qu'en élevage conventionnel ici
c'est au tour de huit poulet ou m² et si
nous on a environ deux mille oiseaux
dans le conventionnel on serait
probablement à 3000 3500 oiseaux et les
oiseaux voyez ils peuvent se mouvoir
facilement bon mais là ici on les
effrayer un peu le sait peut-être pas la
réalité mais il ya quand même dans
l'espace autour de chacun des oiseaux
bon évidemment ça descoings il faut pas
se le cacher produire en neuf semaines
au lieu de 5 e à l'épicerie ce soit on
est souvent 50% plus cher au kilo
puis les gens qui l'achètent c'est
vraiment un choix en fait c'est pas
nécessairement les gens qui sont le plus
à essayer damien girard est une
exception dans le paysage avicole au
pays très peu de producteurs ont opté
pour l'élevage biologique encore moins
pour les poulains à croissance lente
mais les choses pourraient changer à
mesure que l'intérêt pour le bien-être
animal grandi
[Musique]
le bien-être animal fait maintenant
partie de l'industrie de l'élevage ce
n'était pas le cas il ya 20 ans
les normes de bien-être animal continue
d'évoluer avec toujours plus de
réglementation fille les producteurs
vont continuer à suivre ce courant elle
pourra voir des animaux qui sont
toujours de la meilleure qualité que ce
soit mais aussi produits dans les
meilleures conditions qui soient pour
chacune des espèces
quand on discute avec les gens ils sont
vraiment contents d'acheter ce poulet là
ça fait partie de leur mission sociale
parce que c'est eux et ont compris que
les choses c'est pas les gouvernements
qui vont les changer si les
consommateurs un par un
[Musique]